l'étrier tri je pose salah est ce que
quelqu'un a déjà vu le diplôme de
coiffure de soria
[Applaudissements]
avant tu l'as dit tsonga qui a dit ça
non c'est pas moi alors c'est pas moi
c'est toi
ouais moi je pense que c'est benjamin
castaldi
benjamin castaldi were here on va
regarder qui a 10 si c'est toi
benjamin qu'est ce qu'il ya basile face
à ces déchets avant de critiquer pas
m'aimer genre s'est alarmé champ du tout
non mais je suis déjà je veux pas croire
une seule seconde que quelqu'un qui est
diplômé de coiffure accepte d'être
coiffée comme ça donc d'après moi c'est
seulement il est magnifique
[Musique]
la cyclassics la caisse qui ça soraya
l'aï vue critique tamuz la tête date
échue en plastique à moi j'ai dit moi
j'ai des cheveux soraya et vous êtes
mais je sais qu'ils me traitent pas
votre préférée autour de la table bah
ils sont tous gentils votre diplôme on
pourra le voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]